so we already looked at Donald Trump
tweeting endlessly during yesterday's
public impeachment hearings and we could
focus in on almost any element of the
testimony and it would be pretty
interesting but since the hearings
mostly confirmed and corroborated what
was already asserted I want to focus
number one on the new claims that were
notable yesterday because there were
some and I also want to focus in on the
reality that Donald Trump and his
followers lack both the attention spans
and the cognitive capacity to recognize
that there was new evidence yesterday
and to be able to parse the testimony
but William Taylor presented new
assertions directly implicating Donald
Trump in the bribery which i think is
how we should refer to it we shouldn't
refer to it as a quid pro quo that can
be confusing it sounds less clear than
what we're talking about here which is
bribery or extortion William Taylor said
yesterday and to me this was the biggest
new allegation from the hearings William
Taylor said yesterday former ambassador
to Ukraine that on July 26 that's the
day after remember the phone call
between Trump and zalenski the Ukrainian
president was on July 25 William Taylor
says that on July 26th the EU ambassador
Gordon Sunland called Donald Trump from
a restaurant Sunland had just met with
Andre year Mac that's a name we've
mentioned before an advisor to the
Ukrainian president one of William
Taylor staff was at that restaurant and
overheard the phone call between Sunland
and Trump and says that Trump asked
Sunland about the status of quote the
investigations and of course that is
understood to mean the smear
investigations of Joe and hunter Biden
that Trump was demanding Ukraine carry
out and publicly announce ambassador
Sandlin reportedly told President Trump
that the Ukrainians were ready to move
forward
according to William Taylor's testimony
yesterday after the call Taylor's
staffer asked sunland what is Trump
think about Ukraine and sunland
responded Trump cares more about the
investigations of Biden that was the
priority for Donald Trump it was the
only thing that Donna
I'm actually cared about let's look at a
little bit of that portion of the
testimony a staff at a restaurant
Besser sahlan called President Trump and
told him of his meetings in cave the
member of my staff could hear President
Trump on the phone asking ambassador
Stalin about the investigations master
Sandlin told President Trump the
Ukrainians were ready to move forward
following the call with President Trump
the member of my staff asked
ambassador's son and what President
Trump thought about Ukraine Wester song
and responded that President Trump cares
more about the investigations of Biden
which Giuliani was pressing for so this
was new yesterday this was not something
that Taylor mentioned during his
previous closed-door testimony why
wasn't it mentioned before because
Taylor learned about it after his
closed-door testimony and before
yesterday's testimony of course now the
reason that I'm highlighting this is
that in hours and hours of testimony
much of it is nuanced detail-oriented
framed within context in history because
that's what's necessary to understand
this I don't know that all six hours
were necessary there were about 30
minutes of grandstanding arguing about
taking votes about subpoenaing the
whistleblower and all this different
stuff but there was much of that time
was spent on important context in
history it can be really easy to miss
the forest for the trees or for it all
to blend together and for us to come
away without wow they talked for a while
but I'm not really sure what we actually
learned from it this was a big deal
because it is a new corroborating claim
to the broader narrative that's been
presented so far but do you think Trump
has the patience or the capacity to
realize this of course not and therefore
Trump tweets that it's a big nothing
burger his followers repeat it and on
and on and on we go this is how Donald
Trump has altered media and our entire
perception of important issues a witness
gives damning testimony of what is
obvious and apparent wrongdoing by
Donald Trump but Trump and his media
sycophants like those at Fox News
complain that the testimony wasn't
explosive it wasn't interesting
effectively saying it wasn't
entertaining enough it wasn't enough
like an action movie because it was just
people
talking for six hours and in addition to
the new evidence that we just talked
about we also got confirmation of many
other things we got confirmation that
officials that were sort of surrounding
this entire exchange between Trump and
Ukraine at the Trump administration in
Ukraine really they saw Rudy Giuliani's
behavior as both dangerous and
unprecedented that's important people
who tried to raise alarm about what's
going on were either ignored or silenced
that was in yesterday's hearings but you
wouldn't know that if you looked at
Trump's tweets or watched Fox News
Trump's pressure on Ukraine was not
merely a request it was real pressure it
was a attempted extortion or bribery so
this is just the beginning we might feel
like not much was accomplished yesterday
and I understand that but we at number
one corroboration of just about
everything
that we were told before yesterday and
number two the new evidence about this
phone call between Donald Trump and
Gordon Sunland and then tomorrow we have
another hearing this time with Murray
Ivanovich are you Voinovich who was
targeted by a trump Rudy smear campaign
and I believe may actually be far more
explosive and interesting testimony than
what we got yesterday there's a reason
that the only thing Republicans could do
yesterday's say aren't memories
sometimes wrong and they just droned on
and on for hours not really saying
anything the reason why is because the
substance of yesterday's testimony was
devastating to Donald Trump if you knew
what to listen for if you actually were
paying attention and thinking through
what it is that was being said yesterday
so we will cover we will be live
tomorrow with Murray ivanovich's
testimony I encourage you to watch that
at youtube.com slash the david pakman
show reminder on thanksgiving we will be
having our what i believe is going to be
our last membership drive of the year if
you've been thinking about getting a
membership to the show and you really
should it is going to be the biggest
discount of the year we will notify
everybody on our mailing list to get on
the mailing list go to david pakman.com
you'll see how to sign up I don't
remember if it says mailing list or
newsletter in any case sign up for that
and then on Thanksgiving you will be
notified about this extraordinarily
explosive offer that will be available
for one day follow me on Twitter at D
Pakman let me know what you think about
yesterday's impeachment inquiry hearings
agree with me disagree with me a little
bit of both I want to hear from you the
David Pakman show is possible thanks to
sponsors like VIN Charo
watches giving everyone in our audience
15% off your entire order when you go to
david pakman.com slash watch I just got
a couple of new watches from these guys
and I love them I got the Kairos limited
release gold reserve set which is very
cool I love the white face the simple
band and everything about it it's a
perfect size for my wrist really great
choice I also picked out the Ventura
bellwether in silver and white and what
I love about this one number one the
Roman numeral at the top of the face the
white face is great this is a
chronograph model and I love the blue
leather band it's just a really nice
looking watch everybody who sees me wear
this one always asks about it what I
like about Vince arrow as a watch brand
is you're getting quality and you're
getting a watch where it's clear as soon
as you open the box that a lot of care
and artisanship went into the design and
the way that the watch is put together
I'm not interested in paying thousands
of dollars for a watch when I can get
one that's reasonably priced and looks
just as nice and has terrific build
quality and that's exactly what vince
arrow is in the business of doing
putting a ton of craftsmanship into
their watches making them available for
a hundred and fifty two hundred bucks
you really can't go wrong check them out
at david pakman.com slash watch support
the people who support our show and
you'll save fifteen percent when you use
that link